you are so recognizable and such an
iconic figure that you don't think that
you've seen Carol Burnett when you see
Carol Burnett you know you you've seen
her how do you when you're flying on an
airplane do you get self-conscious do
people talk to you that they all want to
there is carbonate I want to speak to
very very sweet very there was one time
many many years ago I was in a movie
with Walter Matthau and Jack Lemmon
called the front page I know it yeah
well and I was terrible in it I was just
awesome well I disagree but I know
you're not happy with it but I I thought
you were terrific no you're the host and
you're very nice anyway so I I didn't
want to see the movie I did not want to
see because I knew I really I was I
stank so now I'm on an airplane and this
was when they called them stewardesses
you know and so forth and so I'm on this
airplane I'm flying to New York from LA
and the stewardess got on the microphone
you know and I'm in this first class
here and she said we're very honored
we're showing a movie today call the
front page oh my god
and we're very honored that we have one
of the people one of the stars of the
movie miss Carol Burnett is that I'm
good Oh God oh and people are turning
around and they're looking and they're
smiling and you know smiling back and so
you know all the shades go down and the
movie starts and I'm just like this and
I kind of watched it and I was as bad as
I thought I was and I was oh god oh no
oh finally it's over all the shades come
up nobody turned around away so I
thought oh what am I gonna do so I went
to the stewardess this was when you
could do this and I said do you think I
could like say something to you know use
the microphone because say she said what
sure yeah I got on the mic and I said
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen this
is Carol Burnett I would like to
apologize to each and every one of them
I felt when I had a I had ace
not on that scale but years ago when we
were doing the show in New York I had to
jump on a plane and fly from New York to
LA and they had was JetBlue and JetBlue
would show the you know TV in real time
so I taped my show I jump on the plane
we take off and then the planes taking
off and it's heading out to LA and
people start turning on their sets and I
see that one person figures out that my
show is just starting so they all start
to put them on then I start to panic
yeah and I see it's the monologue now I
can't hear it cuz I don't have the
earphones in but I see me come out and
I'm talking and I started to think you
know what was the first up course for
checklist and I thought hey I think the
first joke was pretty good and then I
see me do the first joke and everyone on
it was like ha ha and a guy turned
around and did that to me oh good for
you I was like here and then I thought
wait a minute I had this bad feeling and
I said second chokes I took who that
second choke was not I just said I see
me motion and do the second choke
nothing and the guy turns around and
goes hell that's someone invented
you